which brings me to my next story this
one's crazy man did you see this video
portland driver confronted by armed
group in broad daylight shocking video
shows you guys see this one no no
portland there was a group of armed
leftists patrolling streets and blocking
roads these aren't protesters holding
hands and pulling up banners
literally this is a guy with like a with
like full blackout gear and body armor
with an ar-15 and i think one other guy
and they're blocking cars smashing
windows and pepper spraying people
one guy gets up on you know he's like he
opens his door and he's standing up on
on
on his truck with the door open with his
hand on his hip and he draws his gun
he's holding it low ready
and the guys the antifa guys immediately
pull their guns are pointing their guns
at them
yelling them stop they're blocking the
road all right at some point
he gets out of his car and he actually
draws on one of these guys they tackle
him
take his weapon nothing no the cops are
like is that purpose
the purpose is that far left the the far
left extremists are getting more
militant
and or were they protecting anything or
just arbitrary taking control
taking okay it's patrol it's not a
protest it is
when you march around with guns shutting
things down shutting down streets
smashing windows and attacking people i
mean maybe i shouldn't even we shouldn't
even call that a patrol we should call
it like an insurgency
attacking civilians in their cars no no
joke and there's another video right now
we can't show this i think it's out of
chicago i'm not sure was that chicago
that video that i sent you
which one oh i'm not sure there's uh uh
no context
it might be new york it might be chicago
there's uh a bunch of protesters in the
streets
like they've been doing with impunity
and a car just
slams the gas when the car starts
pulling up we're seeing this more and
more and more
the far left will go around it start
banging on it yeah and it's like these
people are nuts
but because there's never been any real
legal
ramification they're not going to keep
doing it well this person in the car
said screw it slam the gas
and p it's like it's a shocking video
normally when you see these videos where
they're like a car plows through
protesters it's like an suv going like a
mile an hour and they're screaming and
yelling and it just slowly drives away
nah this one was somebody hit the gas
and people went boom
that's what's gonna happen because you
see what happens in portland with this
with this video i don't i don't think
they have that fox news show so they
show a little bit i can't show too much
but we've got a tweet you can see here's
the guys wearing it looks like it might
be body armor it might be actually a
tactical vest like a camelback or
something i don't know for sure
and they're holding they're holding uh
some ar-15s pointing at a regular
regular old guy
you know i thought i was going to
predict this but i said it was going to
be
far right locking down streets and
telling people to f off and get out of
their towns
that's probably stupid because we know
the far left has been increasing
it has been increasingly violent and the
escalation has come from them not
conservatives or
you know rural folk but so here we are
i gotta say i'm almost shocked um that
the
right-wing response hasn't been more
ferocious
and quicker to be honest and i'm
thankful for that because i don't think
it's gonna do any good except just
escalate the kind of civil war which i
think any sane
person would want to de-escalate but um
it's unbelievable like the level to
which this has this has gotten and i
think there's a lot of
you know like i'm i'm i wonder
what the heck our society has done
to allow some of these young people who
are out there blocking cars
uh antagonizing people all this but but
i'm not just blaming the people doing
that i mean obviously they're wrong for
doing that
but it's like how have we and this maybe
as i'm getting older
and that i have kids now i'm feeling
this way where i'm like how have we of a
society
failed these kids so much that this is
where we're at
and i think there's a lot to be said
there and then also i can't believe that
there's so much restraint on the other
side that there aren't more people just
plowing them down
the social pressure the social pressure
on social media you know they're
going through their feeds and they like
these campaigns that are going on
i mean i'm not on instagram but like i
you know there's all
this pressure do certain posts and like
it's insane yeah but everybody
everybody make your your post a a a
blank screen onto your instagram to show
you're in line with and if you don't
but look i'm just saying like you could
you can like
hate antifa and just talk about how
awful they are and i agree i'm not
saying you're wrong to do that i mean
these are like
punk kids who are being destructive and
just barbaric and it's awful
but you know if you zoom out a little
bit
you're like wow we really did like
create a society
where there are these kids where there's
like no
like there's no religion in our society
there's no value
no that's replaced that no discipline
they're growing up in
single mother households they're
medicated from the time they're young
they're pushed into these universities
that don't prepare them for any type of
jobs and just saddle them with all of
this debt
they're just it's just there's nothing
you can never buy you know you come out
of
imagine being one of these young kids
who comes out of a university you've
been fed this far
left-wing propaganda you're now 100
grand in debt
um what prospects do you ever have to
like get married have kids and take care
of a family
you could never afford a house you're
going to go work at starbucks and try to
pay your home they feel like
this is their value it is their value
system no dude that's why it's a cult
the problem is not much of what you what
you said but also consider that these
are people growing up
in the wealthiest conditions in human
history i'm not denying that right so
you're right
but look in the 1700s even if you were
wealthy
you still understood some hardship the
the old saying is that
you a poor person today has better
dental care than rockefeller did the
1900s because technology improved things
so if you were a rich person in 1700s
you still need to understand some basic
things and so the gap between you and
the poor
well what may have been dramatic for the
time is insanely different from today
so you're you're absolutely right
they're wealthier than kings were
at a certain point in time right but
there's so what i'm talking about is
something separate from wealth
what i'm talking about is look my
grandfather was far
poorer than any of us are today and and
suffered through
more hardships than any of us could
imagine i mean he was a jew who escaped
nazi germany and then fought in world
war ii
i mean just a very hard life and worked
in a factory that's all he ever did for
his life but with that job
he could he got married his wife my
grandmother didn't work
he took care of two kids owned a house
owned two cars
played poker on the weekends like you
could you could
take care of a a wife and kids
and have an identity and a life whereas
today even though they're much richer
than that
what are what is your chances of owning
a home
getting married paying for the cost of
education healthcare
i'm saying there's no identity there is
my point you're you're
you're right on the surface but you got
to compare the life of a family in the
40s and 50s to the life of a family
today
we have television we have internet
we've got some of the greatest
technology ever created and we have to
pay for those things that requires labor
as the population expands we get more
specialists and more access to better
technology
we still have to pay for it all right so
sure you know my dad
he was able to you know he actually
worked two jobs when i was younger
and his dad before him worked a single
job you know the greatest generation but
what did they have in their home
many of them didn't have tvs and so the
kids would do chores would would go on
you know uh on
uh paper newspaper routes and they would
be doing some kind of work
so what's happening is we're saying
today you know these kids can't even own
a house yes you can
it's called in the middle of west
virginia and it's a 30 000 house
you just don't want to live in it so
sure there were suburban living when
people didn't have the same access to
utilities when people didn't have access
to the same medication
people today say oh it's we we need
universal health care because people
can't go to the doctor
dude the medical care you can get on
debt is a hundred times better than
medical care they were getting a hundred
years ago or a couple hundred years ago
when they were injecting people with
mercury or whatever for
for syphilis nothing is stopping a
person from taking their family
and going and building a cabin in the
middle of the woods except i guess
for the fear eventually the federal
government will wander off into the
middle of wyoming and we'll be mad at
you about it so
so i i don't completely disagree with
you i think that the fact that we've
become richer than ever before is a good
thing and i think the fact that we have
luxury goods and consumer goods for
cheaper than ever before i think it's
great i mean it's risen the standard of
living
i guess it's just the fact that we've
also in this process
created uh through our elected
politicians
this system where we've subsidized the
cost of housing subsidize the cost of
education
subsidize the cost of health care to the
point that they've all been tremendously
inflated
and we've also just lost a sense of
community and values which i think also
goes hand in hand
with the the government taking more and
more of a of a participatory
role in society and i think this is just
again i'm not disagreeing with you it's
just a cocktail that's worked out to be
what we see now we need uh people need
to
to have a a return to like normalcy and
understanding of the world what that
means is
imagine life if you were just one day
woke up in the middle of the woods bug
[ __ ]
congratulations that's life everything
we've built i'm sorry i shouldn't even
say we
everything ev every shoulder that is
being stood upon by the giants
is done for us we woke up i was in new
york one day
and i was riding my bike over the
williamsburg bridge and i was like
wow i never did anything to deserve this
bridge
to ride up and over this river and i had
to i just imagine i'm like what it must
have been like a couple of years ago
when people were like waiting for the
ferry they had to pay for to do it and
then some people said
i am going to plant this tree whose
shade i know i will never sit beneath
because in 50 years the children will be
able to and their lives will be better
today people are now demanding and
entitled of all of these things that
were gifted to us that we never paid for
and so what happens is they say
i should be able to have a massive house
five bedrooms
i should be able to only have to work
you know certain amount of time
throughout the week so i can have every
luxury
that this life can afford me and it's
like nah
you're spoiled i'm sorry but it's true
if you had to go crash land on an island
somewhere
and then build a house out of coconuts
or whatever that's life
yeah we are living a gifted life you
know people came before us yeah you're
so right and you know what's interesting
about that is that
like kind of what you're getting at is
that this idea of like the philosophical
idea of ubi
right like we kind of already have that
i mean like just in
with in just a pure free market with no
government giving you a ubi
you kind of already have this where just
for
the because we were born here in a first
world country in 2021 and we're living
we and we do stand on the shoulders of
all of these people i mean
we none of us really earned all of this
technology that
we get to speak through i mean you may
have bought the microphones and stuff
but we didn't invent all of it and we
whether we have all these things like
you were saying with the bridge and the
trees that other people have you know
molded it before us the bridge is a
better example than the microphones
because that's something you can just
use that paying for well sure but i'm
just saying that even if you pay for
this someone else invented it and we all
benefit from the fact that other minds
put in all of this labor to make all of
this happen
and just the fact that we have this
level of wealth around us i mean we
could be the exact same people
born in some third world country or on
some desert island and we don't get any
of that
so that is our ubi but to your other
point about that which i think is the
real
it's almost like the the contradiction
of the human experience
is that even though there's this kind of
selfish impulse
to go well no we don't care about
passing it on to the next generation
and you go like well look all of this
was passed on to you
so don't you have some obligation to
pass it on to the next generation but
i'll tell you this
after having kids it really you know
opened my eyes up to this that
there's it's actually a much more
rewarding existence you will be a much
happier person
when you are focused on passing
something on to the next generation
that's like the
beauty of life that when you're living
for others and thinking about what's
been given to you and what you can give
on to the next generation
that's when you don't want to go block a
car in the street and throw a molotov
cocktail
through the window because you've got
something kind of bigger to live for
they don't have kids
well that's that's what i'm saying and
so so you can be a person of empathy
and community without having kids sure
if you if you
if you uh you know so we as a society
but it helps
it absolutely throws it in your face but
so you have people
who don't have family don't have
community
they they create these nebulous online
communities of disparate beliefs that
make no sense
and then they're angry that they're not
getting what they think they deserve
they're not working
they don't want to work they want to
make the government pay for it extract
the wealth out of the system to give to
them
and they will get violent this is
it is what's the right way to describe
it it is um blasphemy
no no no it's it's it's a chaotic
destructive force
like fire jealousy that is burning at
the foundation it's a rot
at the foundation of our society of
people who think they're entitled to
things but won't work for things what's
happening
and it's corrupting the foundations and
if we don't do something about it
which should be associated they think
they're helping by not having kids
that's what their argument is because
they think you know we're overpopulated
i don't think we should
a lot there's a lot of people i think
but that's irrational
yeah exactly so what i think is actually
happening is
they're extremely selfish they want
everyone to give to them
they don't understand what it means to
give back and so
as you've mentioned it's a
rationalization oh well i'm doing this
because
you know bad for the planet okay you
know
i think a lot of it is wealth disparity
because we are super wealthy all of us
but the disparity is greater than it's
ever been and if you've ever been
poor in a room with a bunch of rich
people and like
you're having a great everyone's having
a great time you're all equals then all
of a sudden you're like i gotta go
do some crap job i hate and they're all
like i don't because i my dad was rich
and i
i don't ever have to do anything and the
anger that you feel
well i i i i don't know of jealousy it's
almost irrational anger you felt that
yeah i've never felt that yeah i felt
like why do i have to be the one that
has to go work a low-paying job because
my parents weren't rich
when i my friends don't have to worry
that's probably the end and they were
driving around in car
exactly and exactly because i didn't
have that so
i grew up uh uh someone mentioned
earlier take a shot of tim
mentioned south side of chicago now's
your chance i just did uh and so
a lot a lot a lot of crackheads a lot of
heroin addicts a lot of poor people
and then i started you know playing
music which you know
i went around to different uh venues met
different people in different areas
eventually met a bunch of rich kids and
i never cared
i don't i don't care i don't care about
what that person is doing
it's it's a waste of my time to sit
there and be like why do they have money
i was like their parents are rich
whatever
i'm gonna focus on doing my thing but
you know what maybe i'm lucky enough to
have
to be grounded in reality to understand
something really simple
anybody listening here's what you do if
you're in a big city
even today stand in a street corner and
say cheeseburger
and look people that's a cheeseburger
cheeseburger eventually someone will
come back and back i got you
cheeseburger buddy
i'm not kidding it will work i i'm dead
serious
you can go to any major city because
people
tend to be good and want to help yeah
and you can say
to any random person help me buy
cheeseburger but but hold on you're
right
go go go to sub-saharan africa go to the
middle east
go to egypt and see what happens if you
sit there and beg for this stuff
people are going to be like is that is
that a joke yeah sometimes a lot of
countries
i think sure the essence of the point
you're making which is is absolutely
right is that our
our crisis is not a true crisis of
real poverty that's not the issue
exactly like even our poor people
are rich people homeless compared to
other societies that have existed so
that's not the problem and again
maybe this is just like the way i look
at things
since being a father but when i look at
somebody
who's out on the streets like one of
these antifa members
who's this little punk kid who's dressed
in all blacks some of them who wear
these bro
well okay fine but he's still a punk kid
in his 40s
who will you know like you know the way
they fight where it's not even like
someone like like there's no
honor in even being like like why don't
we take this outside and fight it's like
they'll go talk [ __ ]
and then someone stands up to them and
they run away and then they look at the
other guy and then they sucker punch him
behind
him and then they all pound on him when
he's down i go i look at that and go
who raised you nobody like who
and and what what what was your who were
your parents who were responsible for
instilling
something into you the federal reserve
well well that's part of it
but it's there were real human beings
who made this
human being and i'm just saying that we
lost it's not an issue of
poverty it's something different than
that it's it's it's like the soul of the
culture
like we lost this thing that you honor
yes honor and some type of social
pressure
to raise your damn children so i was
i was i was thinking about this the
other day
scruples are gone people people used to
genuinely feel remorse
if they if they you know stole or or
or lied to somebody it's it's great
maybe i'm romanticizing the past
but community used to be like i can't do
that why well because you can't do it
you know it's just like deep within your
soul you feel something you can't do
scruples
now it's like people are like oh i'll
lie to whoever get whatever i want
the moral foundation is being shattered
did you see uh i saw someone was sharing
this
clip like an old alex jones clip on
twitter today where he's you know
it's like a classic alex jones clip
where he's screaming like a maniac but
if you listen to what he's saying he's
actually making a pretty good point
what was your time was like 90 of alex
jones
you're like man if you were just not
yelling at me i'd agree but you were
playing the frogs again
it was old it was like it must have been
like 15 years old but he's talking about
how he's like the kids are worshiping
justin bieber
and they're worshiping you know imagine
and he goes what about magellan
magellan around the world and he's like
that is amazing
he's screaming at you but you're kind of
like i mean he's making a good he was
my favorite he's like there were two
hundred men on that ship and only eleven
made it
dude if you weren't pulling your hair
out of your head like i'd say you're
making a very logical point wait but
that's there's part of this right like
there was no tradition and honor
and like upbringing for for children and
i'm just saying that i think a lot of
times
today at least i get this a lot that if
you if you address any of these issues
people say they they go oh you're like
some social conservative right winger or
something like this and
and then the implication is almost one
step away from like well you must hate
gay people or hate trans people or hate
black people or something like that
but we're not allowed to ever just go
and i feel this a lot more these days
but you just go like you know you go on
instagram and see all the like you know
every girl's like in a thong
and everything you're like these values
suck
this sucks as a culture to raise a
daughter in like it's not this is not
good before we move too far i have to
make one point
uh on your alex jones thing you remember
when he was talking about
turning the frog's gay that's like
probably the most famous alex jones meme
he's yelling and he's like they're
turning the freaking frogs get any light
you know pounds
imagine if instead of that you had alex
but no one had ever seen him before
right it's the first time he's ever
appeared
he's wearing a you know like a a tweed
sweater or something or whatever
he's got like leather patches and he's
got a corn cob pipe he's wearing glasses
and he goes
now an interesting study came out about
atrazine it's a pesticide and he's
talking to
other you know glasses individuals he
goes the interesting thing about this
atrocity is
it's disrupting the endocrine systems of
of amphibians notably frogs
in in many of these regions now on the
coasts you can see that it's draining
off into the oceans
having less of an impact on groundwater
but in the middle east it's a very
serious problem
dare i say jokingly they're turning the
frogs gay now
no no but in all seriousness is it there
would never be a meme
it was alex jones yelling and slamming
they're turning the frog
that's the trump phenomenon right like
when everyone everyone would be like man
if he just didn't if he wasn't so brash
and he didn't do all this
then maybe he could have gotten this
done and you're like no he'd never be
there right
that's the whole thing right yeah that's
the contradiction is he'd never be there
if he hadn't
the reason trump was president is
because he was the guy
who was willing to look at jeb bush and
go your brother lied us into war
and basically wink wink nod nod
you can't pleasure your wife was
basically the measure but that was
basically what i mean what do you think
low energy was
really saying what he kept telling he
kept going jeb bush your low energy what
was it like what was the real
implication of that yeah but he wasn't
wrong and then no he'd clap
he clearly wasn't that's why he won
because he was clearly dead right
and then even he could look at hillary
clinton and go yeah and nasty woman and
all these things
and that's part of why he won but it was
also his downfall you know and that so
that's that's the thing with alex jones
right
but there is something there's a really
important principle there and
from my perspective and maybe this is my
own libertarian bias
but i really do think that the
government
the rise of the welfare state the rise
of big government uh
big government in america that they
undermined
the all the bonds that used to hold
people together right so instead of the
welfare state you would have communities
you would have
churches you would have neighborhoods
all of these bonds and that as the state
got more and more powerful they
destroyed all of these bonds
intentionally in the same way that the
communists hate religion because they
hate anything that's that's a
unifying force more powerful than the
state thanks for checking out this clip
from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at 8
pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you